everyone and thank you all for joining
me for this rather unconventional talk
for pi data conference quanta mental
investing my name is Fabian Klaus and I
run the Kwan technology team at Man GOG
and the purpose of this team is
essentially to bring quanta mental
approaches to life build systems around
quanta mental and help all portfolio
managers make better decisions who have
you knows the term quantum mental who is
heard of it and who of those actually
know what it means cool so most most of
you will learn something something very
new today spoiler alert
there will be no Python code in this
presentation I'm sorry about that but
I'll share what kind of systems we're
building around the the idea of quantum
mental investing what kind of lessons
lessons we've learned in the last couple
of years and also how Python helps us to
bring these to life so man GOG is part
of man group and we are operating
worldwide we have large institutional
client base mainly sovereign wealth
funds endowments pension funds we manage
around one hundred twelve billion
dollars and we are split roughly and in
five business units we've got HL in
numeric on the quantitative side we've
got Man GOG the part of the business
that I now work in as our discretionary
manager we also have a private markets
business and in DPM and the multi
manager and frm the the main takeaway
years that we're doing quite a lot of
things at quite a large scale yeah we
have 25 to 30 years experience in both
the systemic and the discretionary space
in Man Group is a very tech driven tech
driven company we've basically
consolidated all our front office
technology under the new umbrella of man
AlphaTech all based on Python so we're
we're essentially in the perfect place
to bring these quanta mental approaches
to life to get this fusion going between
discretionary and systemic trading and
don't worry I've already used quite a
lot of Finance terms I'll make sure that
we speak the same language in just just
a bit so my rough goal for today is to
give you an idea of what quanta mental
investing is why what do we actually
need it we already have big businesses
around systemic trading about
discretionary trading what does it
actually
what kind of problems doesn't solve then
I will give you an overview of what kind
of systems we've actually built to help
out but for your managers make better
decisions and also share share the
lessons learned in the last couple of
years but let's make sure that we all
speak the same language quant or
systematic trading is essentially a
computer driven trading algorithms make
the decisions we have one researchers
who come up with a model as to how to
use market data transferred in different
ways you stats use machine learning to
come up with a signal as to whether to
buy or to sell certain instruments build
it but for year round it and then
execute that in the market the
characteristic of such portfolios is
generally that you have a large number
of instruments or stocks when you when
you trade cash equities you almost have
like an unlimited ability to process
data depending on what what your
clusters about the cluster is capable of
depending on what kind of machines you
have you have in your new company so the
main selling point around systematic
trading is you're following a model you
take the emotions out of the game and
you make let the computers just do do
its thing on it on a daily basis however
you can also only use a quantifiable
information anything that is not
specified up front and your model you
can't really incorporate into your
trading process so you limit it to that
we got on the other hand discretionary
trading and that's also where the space
that man GOG operates in is driven by
humans humans analyze companies they
meet with the company boards they look
at broker reports they look at news
events they incorporate all kinds of
information about a certain company in
the trading process and make up their
mind as to whether to sell or to buy
certain certain companies these
portfolio is obviously quite
concentrated because our we humans were
quite limited in our ability to process
data so we can only look at so many
companies or so many instruments but we
are also able or discretionary portfolio
managers are able to use non
quantifiable information anything that
that comes comes up about around the
company about ear on an instrument
anything that is not even related to
these companies but might have some
macro effects that can be incorporated
in your trading process and quanta
mental is really the blend of these two
just you take quantitive techniques you
take fundamental investing you mix in
some data if you're really fancy
nowadays you call it alternative data so
credit card data or satellite images to
track the number of cars in front of
shops to come up with an idea of whether
they're doing well or not
and eval are you get your new password
of the discretionary community quanta
mental but to make all this a little bit
more tangible for you let's look at the
trading process and the way I see the
trading process I roughly divided in
five stages obviously there are
different ways and how how you can do it
but in my mind you start with the
universe screening stage you need to
narrow down the amount of instruments
that you could trade to the amount that
you actually want to do research on or
want to run your models on in a
discretionary environment obviously a
portfolio manager I can't meet with all
companies a world why they need to
narrow that down systematic signals or
systematic strategies want to usually
look at the most liquid names so they
throw out less liquid instruments so
that it can quickly trade in and out of
positions and then once you have your
universe you start doing fundamental
research on that universe you meet with
the company boards you read broker
research and you make up your mind as to
whether you like certain instrument or
you don't like it in a systemic
environment that might just be number
crunching exercise you take market data
and run your model and come up with the
signal as to whether to buy or to sell
certain instruments once you have these
instruments and you have your indication
as to whether you would like them or not
you build a portfolio around them you
run a portfolio optimizer and you
execute that in the market in the last
step you you look at how we put four
years doing what you want to monitor
whether you you're actually making money
whether you're losing money whether your
original ideas pan out in a systemic
world you also want to see whether the
simulation that you came up with or that
you put your researcher came up with in
the Python environment actually reflects
your life trading P&L and the way we
seek wonda mental is essentially
enrichment of the traditional
discretionary managers trading process
by a technology each of these five
stages will be enriched by technology
will be enriched by kuan techniques and
we'll try to make them better at what
they do so we see the quanta mental as
an enrichment
fundamental research process use new
data sets combine them in different ways
use quantum nosies to answer very
complex questions that you can't do just
with Excel spreadsheets and I'll give
you a couple of examples of what we've
done in the past later on and also you
can use Kwan signals in your universe
screening stage we've built sentiment
indicators using NLP on earnings called
transcripts to give all portfolio
managers and I an idea of whether it was
a good a positive or a negative earnings
call also you can use breakout signals
we also think about quantum ental in
terms of all the tools that deal with
behavioral biases and are given to
behavioral biases in and in a few
moments lastly even though that's not
it's not quite quanta mental but we also
use it under the same umbrella as
essentially generating efficiencies for
portfolio managers we want to make sure
that in the trading process that you
just saw you the the portfolio managers
or we automate that the stages that can
easily be automated by computers where
they're basically wasting their time for
example copying data from one
spreadsheet to another writer you don't
need a human to do that there are lots
of lots of systems that can do that so
that they can really focus on their
value add focus on their fundamental
research process look at more company do
more in-depth analyses and become better
investors as a as a whole but I've
already told you that we have large
businesses around the systemic side
discretionary aside they're huge
industries build around both approaches
why do we actually need anything quantum
and what does it give us on top and as
Python enthusiasts and computer
scientists you probably think well I
can't just build a computer model that
does everything for me
right well the problem is you know when
you work in complex domains you can't
really come up with a proper
mathematical model to model reality
perfectly yeah they're always changing
underlying assumptions new market
conditions might change how do you put a
brexit into your model
yeah and for fans of Nassim collapse
work on the black swan a lot of the kuan
techniques are also based around the
idea of normality of your data and that
might not be really the case in real
life a couple of examples where were
these where we can't really build
systematic strategies around around
certains to a certain
ideas or investment ideas are for
example merger arbitrage yeah for for
making money out of different mergers
companies you really need to understand
the legal the legal groundwork yeah we
weren't able to come up with computers
they can actually do that job for us so
we have humans looking at that and
another really good examples index
events for those of you who don't know
index providers MSCI or footsie they
basically define their base universes so
for example the MSCI world contains the
biggest companies in the world then you
have ETFs who map these indices we
actually make them accessible for you as
an individual to trade on them to get
exposure to them to get the same returns
that your index would what would get
these ETFs essentially need to rebalance
every time the index comes up with a new
list of stocks which should be in and
out of here next yeah so so on a
quarterly basis they'd have these big
rebalance events and you would think
that MSCI and footsie they provide me
with a detail rulebook I think the MSC
is is around eight hundred pages long so
you can you convey city code that up
step by step and come up with your
prediction that on each day you know
what should be in the index and what
shouldn't the problem is that these
index providers also apply quite a lot
of discretion in the in their process so
for example in May 2019 Argentina was
moved from being a frontier market to
becoming an emerging market and that
essentially I mean doesn't really sound
like a big deal of emerging market
frontier why what does that even mean
but it essentially means that your your
base universe of companies who should be
in each of these buckets changes
completely and you will get all your
predictions wrong because if you and
these index events trades if you get one
prediction wrong you basically get them
all wrong yeah and so you if you're
trading index events you really need a
human analyst who keeps in touch with
the index providers who keeps in touch
with the broadcast force the news to
anticipate these these changes and make
sure that your model is not not
completely going rock so should we just
let humans make all of the decisions
then we'll go back to traditional
trading well you all know that we're
quite limited in our ability to process
data we are very bad at statistical
reasoning and in order to become really
good at something we require a frequent
feedback loop that is not really given
in
ancient markets because you will never
encounter the same situation twice right
market conditions will always change
even just like a small variable might
might be different next time you
encounter similar conditions and we
underlie behavioral biases I just want
to spend a few minutes looking at
behavioral biases and how they affect
our decision-making most of you will be
familiar with Daniel Kahneman his work
on cognitive limitations behavioral
biases he published his popular book
Thinking Fast and Slow around how our
decision-making is impaired by these
biases he essentially thinks of our
human mind and in terms of two systems
system one being the system that is
responsible for for fast decision making
our intuitive intuitive part of the
brain and then you got the system tool
which is the lazy the reasoning parts
every time your system one can't handle
can't handle a question a new task and
it will defer back to system two and
system two becomes active and things
more deeply about around it and I won't
go into all these biases but I just want
to give you an overview of how some of
them might affect decision-making in
financial markets so I'll give you an
idea of what the anchoring effect is an
example of the framing and then we go
into overconfidence as well so the
anchoring bias essentially means that an
initial piece of information that you
see disproportionately affects you how
you see the world even though you see
lots of other even-even encounter
encounter arguments for it afterwards so
for example your your favorite broker
gives you a buy recommendation for
Vodafone yeah
if you then see lots of other brokers
saying no Vodafone is not really a good
stock you might still be biased toward
this this initial piece of information
and the way the way count amendments
colleagues test that and did the studies
on that was essentially to give
participants in two groups the same task
essentially create the product of the
first eight integers both of these
groups didn't have enough time to come
up with the correct answer they didn't
have enough time to do the mental
arithmetic and so they had to come up
with an educated guess the first group
was tasked to multiply numbers in an
ascending order 1 times 2 times 3 etc
the second group in descending order
times seven times six and what they
found was that group one significantly
underestimated the the true result so so
when you start with the one multiplying
1 by 2 by 3 you significantly annum
estimate the true result similarly on
the group that overestimated the true
result they they did the group
multiplying numbers in a descending
order they they overestimated the result
significantly so you can see how that
affects our decision making when we
actually have to look at financial
information and different different
pieces of information from our brokers
et cetera an example of the how the
framing effect might a framing effect
might affect our decision-making would
be to look at what what a drug can do
for you alright you you can either frame
it as this drug this drug cures the
disease in 90% of the cases or you could
say that even though taking this drug
10% of the of the trials or trial list
died using this drug and obviously you
felt a lot about overconfidence already
over confidence in financial markets is
also a problem if you if you think
you're better than you actually are
and the traditional research and
overconfidence was done by Rousseau on
his work on decision traps and what he's
doing is essentially he gives
participants a list of 10 questions and
for each of these 10 questions
participants are tasked to come up with
confidence intervals 90% confidence
interval give a lower bound give an
upper bound so that you're 90 percent
confidence that the true results will
lie within those and if you are well
calibrated human being you will get 9
out of these 10 questions right if
you're overconfident in your ability to
answer these questions you'll get get
much fewer right so in his original work
he found that most participants only got
four or fewer few of these answers or
these confidence intervals right showing
that there's great overconfidence in
answering these these questions and
we've replicated that actually at
Mangione last year because we thought
well maybe if you're an educated human
being you know a lot of stuff you can
actually calibrate your your
your confidence pounds a lot a lot
better and this is essentially the list
of questions that we use so we added
some listed equity market cap of the
world today a number of employees at man
group so things that you you either know
and because you've read read them or you
need to make make an estimate and we
found the same same results essentially
80% of our 46 respondents only get five
or fewer of these these whites so even
even in our case there's a lot of
overconfidence at play and that is also
very in line with the academic
literature on that barababa and odine
made did a study in 2013 investigating
the behavior of individual investors and
what they found was clear sign of
overconfidence and also clear signs of a
disposition effect so the tendency to
sell winners and as hold on to losers
and that's for individual investors
that's not only a bad investment
strategy in terms of your returns but
it's also really bad in terms of text
reasons but you might not think well
individual investors we all have
behavioral biases obviously individual
and vessels are not quite as experienced
as professional investors so do experts
actually do better honest well there's a
study that recently came out and I won't
even try to pronounce the name because
I'll just make a fool out of myself but
the researchers essentially investigated
783 long-only portfolio managers
long-only meaning that you can't short
sell any stocks you basically always
have to take a positive position in
something and what long-only portfolio
managers generally do is they try to
replicate a benchmark and then over
underway it starts according to what
kind of conviction they have around them
and these portfolio managers manage
portfolios that were quite large so an
average the portfolio size was 573
million dollars so you would think that
if you're an expert you you don't run
into these behavioral biases and you you
actually ya find find reasonable and
make reasonable investment decisions but
they found that they even though these
portfolio managers had a clear skill in
buying they're selling performance
actually underperformed and they
compared what what they've done on the
selling side against a random strategy
so instead of selling the stock that is
but for your managers choose to sell and
they actually chose another stock
randomly from the portfolio and then
compared compared the performance of
these two strategies and they found that
the random strategy essentially
outperformed on average by eighty bits
to a percent on an annual basis which is
quite a lot considering the per support
for the portfolio size and so what why
is that the case all right
they found that but for these portfolio
managers they're very biased towards
selling stocks that had extreme returns
so either on the positive side or on the
negative side the you could come up with
you know with a proper economic
rationale as to why they would do that
yeah if your stock has an extremely
positive return you might think well my
original idea worked out let's make sure
that we we lock in some of the gains
before before it crashes down again on
the other hand on the negative side you
might think well my my idea didn't
really work out I probably did my
research wrong let's get out of it cut
our losses but what the authors also
found by by interviewing these portfolio
managers was that they had a very
limited attention span in the in the
selling performance right they they only
saw selling as a means to raise funds to
fund the next buys and due to this
limited attention span what the authors
essentially hypothesized was that it is
because of the availability heuristic
that they are actually shooting these
dogs because starts with extreme returns
they will be very prominent on the media
right if you if you go on Bloomberg or
Financial Times if there is a stock that
had a 20% return in the last three
months it's sure that they it will be it
would be on there and these portfolio
managers those will have exposure to
these starts and will have them in their
mind they come come to might come to
their mind easily when they need to make
a decision as to what to sell or what to
buy and another another good good
argument as to why why this availability
heuristic might be a play here
is that they also investigated what
happens if it's not just a normal
selling normal sell but it's actually a
sell around certain events so if there's
an earnings announcement coming out from
a company does selling around these
events
essentially it will show the same
performance that the usual selling
tivity does and and they found that it
doesn't it's very much in line with
their buying skills so they are they
actually doing very well when they sell
on actual announcement it's only when
they really sell to raise funds that
they they underperform random strategies
so this just shows you how behavioral
biases might actually affect affect our
decision-making in financial markets so
I've not told you what what kind of
problems you have with systematic
trading and with discretionary trading
but obviously they are they're big
industries built around that I'm not I'm
not saying these are completely invalid
right I mean they they have their merits
and the only thing I'm saying is that
there might be something that we can do
in top to mitigate some of these
problems and I'll show you a couple of
systems that we that we've built around
making our portfolio managers just a
little bit better removing some of these
biases and making sure that they can can
compete against computer systems and
indicates their peers in the future so
what you need to know about but for your
managers and analysts that's
traditionally the use of technology was
very limited yeah you rock up at a shop
you get a Bloomberg terminal you get an
Excel spreadsheet and off you go
for the last 25 30 years that work well
for them so why would they why would
they change right what's what's there
that they can't do in in their
traditional world well first of all it's
like the amount of data nowadays it's
much bigger yeah you need to compete
with all the systemic strategies that
use all kinds of data sources you need
to compare people your peers which which
are already looking at data in different
ways might use more sophisticated
technology
so boom burg and Excel doesn't doesn't
cut it anymore and we're actually
bringing our Excel spreadsheets to their
limits we have a couple of plugins which
do pricing which do analytics and but
even even that it's just just not enough
to process the amount of data that is
out there
so what we are building we're basically
enriching these traditional systems with
our Python platform yeah we're we are
building analytics tools we'll building
back testers we give our analysts
stupider notebooks and build everything
around around our data on top of MongoDB
and our active
sauce text or if our analysts are very
tech savvy that we also give them UNIX
environment which they can use to
actually schedule jobs on a daily basis
get to get more data in and and and do
even even more complex and all these one
good example of how that has actually
helped us to make a Kwanza know analyst
better is last year in September that
was the panga classification so Facebook
Amazon Netflix Google they were
reclassify was reclassified and the gigs
and the Global Industry Classification
standard from IT to communication
systems yeah and that doesn't really
sound like a big deal well they they're
just moving moving from one sector to
another but one of our portfolio
managers approached us and said hey what
does that actually mean for my portfolio
alright do I have any any factor tilts
that are not hatched afterwards can I
can I do anything to exploit this
process and will I be completely
completely under hatch and some of these
sectors afterwards so and these the
scenario knows isn't getting just
getting all the data in place and then
doing all the Audion Alice's and on the
risk side probably would have taken them
our Kwan's a week or more to actually
perform but using our Python analytics
libraries and everything we have in in
one go it basically took them an
afternoon to come up with a strategy for
portfolio manager to do better and
basically navigate this this change and
talking about data data is not really a
competitive differentiator anymore you
won't be the only user of a certain data
set yeah so in financial markets is
really important to combine data sets in
smart ways to ask the right questions
visualize your results effectively and
also get get your interpretation right
so we found that the partners and then
pandas num files is the perfect perfect
ground for letting our analysts do more
sophisticated analyses so that they can
actually extract value out of these data
sets and not not just get a new data set
and use it as everyone else because that
just doesn't cut it anymore but building
this platform is not the only thing that
we do I always like to think about this
as human-machine symbiosis so we are
building systems that work alongside our
portfolio managers and
make make them better at the job so one
one example of how we do that is in our
Center book our Center book is
essentially a book that runs internally
looks at our portfolio managers
positions looks at who's doing great
who's not doing so great who's doing
great under what circumstances run
signals on top of them and then trades
these positions systematically so it's
basically replicating internal portfolio
managers ideas trading them in a more
systematic fashion the one metaphor that
our portfolio manager for the center
book always uses is using Lewis Hamilton
as our portfolio manager yeah it was him
old as the word class driver and what we
in the context to do is we try to build
like a mini Hamilton Robo hammer and we
try to build a system that actually
learns from Hamilton's experience learns
from his mistakes and becomes better and
better and tries to outpace Hamilton in
the long run once that mini Hamilton
becomes becomes good enough
Lewis might actually think well this guy
is doing really great and it's just
replicating what I'm doing so what am I
doing wrong so he's actually looking at
that process and tries to find find ways
to improve his own driving bringing that
to the financial world so what we what
we do is we not only look at the
positions and the trading behavior of
our portfolio managers but what whenever
we find something where they are where
they have systemic biases or whether
there's something that they can improve
we basically feed that back to them give
them give them reports have sessions
with them just just talking them through
what we found and and how how they can
actually improve their their process and
obviously finance is not the first first
industry that it's doing that anything
back at chess when when Kasparov was
beaten by deep blue that wasn't the end
of humans winning against machines that
was just the end of humans by themselves
winning against the computer right there
was a long era of hybrid hybrid yet
teams of computers turn teamed up with
humans which were better than both
humans by themselves and also computers
by themselves
lastly I talked about behavioral biases
and what we try to do with our systems
essentially build systems that guide our
investors to make the right decisions on
their on the left and
you essentially see the the famous
bullaiah illusion on the left-hand side
you would think that the line in the
middle for that for the top graphic is
it's much longer than the one in the
bottom but once you put these decision
boundaries in place you'd actually see
that yeah your mind was just playing
tricks on you and they're actually the
same length so what we try to do with
our systems is essentially it take the
emotions out of the game take the
current state of the mind out of the
game of the portfolio manager and really
minimize the distance between the
intuitive solution and the correct
solution by bullying's yeah designing
systems in a smart way and one one
examples of where we do that is on the
post rate analytics side here you can
see a simple visualization of a stock
price in blue and the position that I'll
put for you held in a portfolio manager
held in in black the green and the red
triangles essentially a buy and sell
decisions and what that gives our
portfolio managers is a way to analyze
whether they went into a trade too late
whether way they they moved out of a
trade too early or whether they even
moved out too late and therefore didn't
really gain the the performance that
they could have gotten if they adjusted
their behavior obviously this is just
like an individual instance but if you
think about that in a broader scale and
basically analyze all traits of a
portfolio manager but I'd run your
Python scripts on top of that use panels
for your 444 year and hours and then
come up with find out that this
portfolio manager is always going out of
positions too early and he's basically
yeah missing out on on I can percent
every year just because he's trading out
too early and we can feed that back to
him and basically design our systems in
a way so that next time he runs into one
of these biases we can guide them to do
- - yeah - make a better decision and
then therefore perform better in the
long run so I've told you quite a lot
about the systems or the kind of systems
that we're building but I also want to
share a couple of the lessons learned in
the last couple of years and how you
could bring these quanta mental
approaches to life in you in your own
firm in your own own asset manager and
these are these are really
I think I think broadly applicable it's
not only for quantum mental approaches
but what we found is that you really
need to work bottom-up yeah you can you
can be really smart about your data
signs and come up with like a really
smart system that you think will help
them make better decisions and become
better investors but if they don't buy
into that they just won't use it and
they won't even look at the data they
already they already overwhelmed by what
they have to look at on a daily basis
and they they can't can't can't take
anything they don't really want so you
have to find champions in your company
and try to identify real needs find
solutions for these real needs and then
make these broadly available
I think that's available in order that's
applicable to all kinds of domains yeah
you have to work bottom-up but what you
also need is is top-down support because
discretionary investment managers they
are very very focused on this this
mindset using Bloomberg terminals Excel
spreadsheets and we can do anything we
want yeah so if your management is not
behind your idea of building these
quantumatic
systems then you basically lost from the
beginning also design and I must admit
I'm not the biggest fan of front-end
design I'm not the biggest designer yeah
you can give me the latest machine
learning libraries I'll be happy for the
next couple of weekends but I'm not I
really dislike front-end work however
it's crucial in the discretionary
environment that you design systems in a
way that they don't hinder their current
workflow yeah portfolio managers I
already have desktops with 20 Bloomberg
screens or broker reports an Outlook is
a big part of their process and you
can't design anything that takes up too
much screen real estate you really need
to build system that that work for them
and that enhance the workflow so in one
way we do that is we use something use
the open fin technology and for those of
you not familiar with what open fin does
they basically brand themselves as the
operating system of Finance and you get
like a chromium browser and a message
bus so that you can run your your web
apps natively connect to your to your
other applications and basically create
this integrated user experience that we
want for portfolio managers well you
don't have isolated systems but
essentially have like one floor right
you you come up you do your analytics
you come up with your trades right one
system starts talks in to another you
you push pushing you're your alphas and
then you can execute it in the market
immediately
lastly data and the same lesson holds
true for data as it did for the fall for
building these systems yeah you have to
you can't really push data top-down if
you just come up with new data sets and
give them to portfolio managers they
won't even look at it yeah you really
need to look at what kind of questions
they have then find data to answer these
questions visualize the results
effectively combine data sets in
different ways and then make that data
more available that more broadly
available if people have already bought
into it so summing all of that up that
I've told you essentially yes you just
merit obviously in the traditional
approaches quant trading I discretionary
trading yeah but they're they're also a
couple a couple of shortfalls and what
we try to do with quantum ental is
essentially enrich to this questionary
portfolio managers investment process
make them just a little bit better than
they were take some of these biases away
so we we are building systems that
minimize the possibility for these
biases we build them in a way so that
they are designed to enrich and enhance
their workflow and hopefully in the long
run make them better better decision
makers on financial markets and an
obviously Python and in all the
libraries I mean you you've seen a
couple couple of the ones that we are
using in our group in man AlphaTech
pandas numpy they are super useful for
for us and everything in our front
office essentially built around Python
and and making making these tools
available to researchers and analysts
alike so before we go into Q&A just
really quick raising of attention to our
open source a crafter in 2019 on the 2nd
of November we're working alongside you
on open source packages in our London
offices so if you're interested in
contributing giving something back to
the community sign up at man dot coms -
hackathon
2019